in the search bar at the top of the page
and now on book tv we're live with
author and journalist nomie prinz her
books include it takes a pillage all the
president's bankers and most recently
collusion how central bankers rigged the
world
nomi prinz in your book all the
president's bankers you describe the
relationship between banks and
governments and presidents as
co-dependent what do you mean
well it what i mean changes over the
decades because i all the president's
bankers covered really from the 1890s
until the obama administration but what
it means is that in times of war there's
a certain relationship where the
government turned to bankers to help
finance it in times of peace the bankers
require of the presidents that they help
them bank more widely
and with fewer rules so depending on
whether there was a financial crisis or
a global war-like situation the
relationship changed but the dependency
of one group on the other continued it
was either about money or it was about
influence but it was pretty much
prevalent in different ways through the
different presidencies that we've had
since well throughout our history but
the history i cover specifically uh
since teddy roosevelt's administration
through till today is there a reason you
picked that starting point
yes um one first of all i didn't it was
um only so much time i had in life
basically to do a couple of centuries
versus one but but really what happened
was um
as we know there was a crisis a crash
black tuesday in 1929 that's not when i
start the book but what i realized when
i researched that crash
was that a couple of the bankers that
were most connected to the crash and
most concerned about it including
bankers from the morgan bank which we
now know as jpmorgan chase
if you trace them back trace back to jp
morgan and jp morgan was one of the lead
bankers in the country from 1890. so
there was this through line of
individuals families and banks that cast
back to that time but also that was a
time under teddy roosevelt's
administration where there was a lot of
kind of recessions going on so there was
times where the country was doing well
and then a couple for a couple years and
then it would sort of recede for a
couple years economically to the point
where in the mid 1890s the government
talked about dependency had to call upon
jp morgan to help them finance
the budget um so so that was what
happened that was kind of the gift that
jp morgan gave and in return he required
influence over his years after that so
that's how it started and then in 1907
that midpoint was when there was a huge
panic
in new york and it required a lot of
banks to close as ultimately happened in
2008 almost 100 years later and at that
point in time teddy roosevelt's
administration turned to j.p morgan
again as they had in the 1890s and he
said what can i do to help you help me
basically
and what happened was the treasury
department fashioned 25 million dollars
it was kind of the first bailout um of
banks that the government paid for um
and said to jp morgan here's 25 million
dollars to figure it out
and what jp morgan did is he gathered in
his library the major bankers at the
time and what he decided to do is parcel
out money to some of them they were all
his friends they had shares with him he
had shares with them they hung out
together their families got together et
cetera and a lot of the other banks
failed at the time
but that was a situation where he then
became known because he let his bank
survive and he saved this panic
as sort of the king of banking
the new york times called him that um as
well so the history goes back through
that period between the 1890s and 1920s
because really around the morgan bank
they were um very influential for for
money and also for what happened
politically and how the treasury
department and the presidency ultimately
uh survived their panic at the time but
nomi prince tr was known for being the
trust buster for not liking big business
or
railing against it at least publicly yes
and he was and he is known as that and
he was a trust buster
what he busted
was non-banks um so at the time standard
oil which was a major oil company under
the rockefeller family and other types
of companies of that nature he actually
did
bust up some of their
more powerful sort of elements to sort
of try to make some more competitive
environment he did do that he was known
as that and in other industries as well
but he stayed away from banks
and if you look at the history of why he
did that i think it snakes back to that
1907 panic he needed
jp morgan to help him
basically not have a larger panic
throughout the united states throughout
the entire country and to keep money
flowing throughout the entire country by
not having runs on all the banks
and i think that element of saving
was something that he required and that
he therefore as a kind of gentleman's
agreement stayed off of busting up the
larger institutions which as a result is
why we have jp morgan chase today really
i mean the fact that he did not bust up
some of the banks back then
is one of the reasons why our larger
banks in this country today
have been able to accumulate that size
and that footprint in in the way that
they have so too big to fail is not a
new concept
no it isn't um it's definitely not the
difference is that more in a recent pass
too big to fail were banks that became
big over this you know this major period
of the past century um and then required
help from the government and the
government
provided that help as did the federal
reserve at the time back then um they
were either helping themselves um
getting some money from the government
to help themselves but it but it was a
bit more sort of limited
before we leave this period there's a
character in your book
that we probably haven't heard of today
james stillman but he seemed to have
this
very influential role
yeah so james stillman was actually one
of the leaders of what was called
national citibank
which now we know is citigroup um so
going back in time he was one of the the
major director of that bank and his
family was a very um sort of upscale
blueberry family in in new york city um
in culture and so forth um but he was
also one of the bankers that after this
period of time and he was friends with
the morgans and so forth um he was one
of the main people that decided it would
be necessary for there to be some sort
of a central bank in the united states
like what we have now the federal
reserve that would be able to save banks
in a situation where the government
couldn't step in and help those banks so
when there was an unstable period like
the panic rather than just jp morgan for
example
counting on the treasury department
which he had furnished money to in
decades before that
there would be some other central entity
that would do that so stillman was one
of the people that sort of behind the
scenes um started to work with congress
to basically create what became
the federal reserve bank but but his
name isn't really noted for that in
history so jekyll island 1913. was that
a noble effort
um so so jekyll island um started in
1910 and it was basically um jekyll
island anyway it was like the country
club for all the sort of rich people in
in the united states at the time
they effectively i i spent a lot of time
doing research down there now it's a
it's a resort hotel in in um
off the coast of georgia but at the time
all of these major families the morgans
the hydes the rockefellers would have
sort of condos there but they weren't
like city condos they were just really
nice and they had lots of servants come
down with them and so forth and they
could only access jekyll island through
the
through the waterways and the rest of
the people had to stay away from it
during the times they were there they
would go down around thanksgiving to
christmas and hang out a particular
thanksgiving around 1910
a very small number of them went before
the families came in for the holidays
to ink what became
the documents that ultimately turned
into the federal reserve act of 1913
which created the federal reserve but at
the time it was all very clandestine and
almost didn't happen i i talk about it
in all the president's bankers it's one
of my favorite stories because nelson
aldrich who was the senator he was the
head of the finance committee actually
um at the time republican rhode island
that's right rhode island that's right
um and you know he had a bit of sort of
wealth and sort of prestige and stuff
himself and he was on he was on the
finance committee as a banking committee
it was called at the time
and he had a son winthrop eldritch who
was living in new york as as a banker um
and he was going to visit him and kind
of talk to jp morgan and others about
you know a central bank and decide where
they could actually have this meeting he
was going to meet in new york um and
then what happened was he got hit by a
trolley car
and so he got laid up he had to
convalesce and during that period rather
than have people know what was going on
it was decided by j.p morgan that
basically aldrich and a bunch of other
people go to jekyll island use his
membership because it was after all a
club um and and convene there and decide
what to do which is ultimately what
happened so all the stories about it
being all secret and whatever they
really happened because nelson aldrich
was in the wrong place at the wrong time
relative to a trolley car so they meet
at jekyll island um they they pen this
these ideas for the central bank based
on their travels based on what was
required based on what they thought
would go through with the american
public if it were voted
and ultimately it was a bunch of bankers
including james stillman who took those
documents back to congress
and and basically brought them into the
senate and to wider committee and
ultimately was not passed in 1910 um
under what was in a republican
presidency it passed under woodrow
wilson um the democrat who came in um
after that presidency to take over um
and it was it was basically sold as this
idea that there'd be a federal reserve
there'd be a central bank that would be
a bank to the banks to help them um when
they needed it but also provide credit
for the country so the idea was if there
was ever to be a panic again like the
farmers in the middle of the country
wouldn't find that their banks couldn't
get money from new york and wouldn't be
able to provide them you know through
that season or through that hardship
and that was kind of how it was sold as
a sort of people's bank but in reality
it was created together
with nelson aldrich and some senators
and
bankers to provide them an out if there
were to be an emergency
based on the european model
to an extent based on the european model
um with with a sort of more um
because our country is bigger than say
the bank of england model or the the
bank of france mall at the time which is
now part of the european central bank um
the idea was we'd have 12 different sort
of entities which were part of the
federal reserve system and that goes
back to the farmers and that goes back
to the idea that if we have 12 separate
entities of which in washington um right
here we have the main one the federal
reserve and we have a new york fed we
have a fed in san francisco and so forth
they would be able to sort of cover um
the local banks in that area in terms of
making sure they had credit when they
needed it regulating them when they had
to and making sure that other banks that
used the big banks
to help workers and farmers and other
businesses throughout the country would
have access to credit and access to
money so our system has more banks in it
to spread out through the country um
politically and also just because
geographically we're bigger and we have
different cities that have more banks in
them for more purposes locally and now
they're more national but but at the
time that was the idea were there
protests against it in 1913 today
there's still an undercurrent of protest
against the fed
um
there were more protests in 1911 and
1912. there are basically more protests
under taft than the president before
wilson than there were during him with
him it was much more
yes there were op-eds and yes there were
concerns that a bank could be too
controlled
by wall street banks but what he did
is decide to use wording and he was even
worried about having a federal reserve
and even was after after the fact but
but he decided to use wording and to
work with politicians throughout the
country particularly in the middle of
the country in those regions to
provide the narrative to the rest of the
country that this money would be good
for everyone you know the idea here was
not to just focus on the big wall street
banks so the big powerful families that
basically ran those banks at the time
but the idea was it would be a way to
sort of smooth out money for the country
so in that respect
he kind of got around
any sort of protests which which were
limited by the time he was in office and
also got around any sort of criticisms
because he got buy-in
from a number of senators and
representatives throughout the country
that ultimately the system
um by being a system of 12 banks would
work for everybody
now no mean prince will return to the
central banks when we get into
collusion your most recent book but i
want to read two things first of all
from all the president's bankers
quote the political and financial
alliances between bankers and presidents
and their cabinets continue to define
the policies and laws that drive the
economy
and then from one of your previous books
other people's money you write that the
amount of clout the financial sectors
wheeled in washington can't be
underestimated
that's that's true
um those are both true statements other
people's money i i wrote in the wake of
the enron scandal and and the worldcom
scandal which were effectively in the
energy and the telecommunications
sectors after um deregulation in those
sectors but but they
happened really because
those institutions enron worldcom were
working with the major banks of the
country on all sorts of derivative
structures hiding money off of their
books and so forth so this scandal
situation happened a recession happened
um everybody knew about it but the banks
kind of got off um relatively free from
that none of you know their ceos went to
jail then this was about 2001 2002. um
during when i wrote after which i wrote
other people's money um but their
influence was very high in washington
because what they were basically saying
was look you know this is this is on
enron you know this is on worldcom this
this is on you know they did things
wrong yeah we might have you know did
some paperwork help them with their
banking here and there but the reality
is those kinds of institutions
enron could have couldn't have become
the major derivatives trader that it
became instead of the energy company it
said it was and worldcom couldn't have
become such a massive organization with
so much stuff hidden um offshore and and
from their books from the public
if banks hadn't helped uh create the
facilities create the credit lines merge
companies together and basically do all
of that so with respect to the influence
in washington
all of that comes to bear so all of the
bankers at the time and throughout our
history have been able either through
money or through just having the ear
of presidents being on committees being
major advisors that they've been able to
say look it wasn't us you need us it was
them and sort of i'm summarizing it but
work it into that um so in terms of all
the president's bankers it's it's really
the same thing except all the
president's bankers i wrote
10 years after i wrote
other people's money but but but in that
book i go through specifically
the kinds of relationships and influence
that bankers had in washington and today
we think mostly of the donations um and
the lobbying which which is immense
compared to other sectors although right
now the tech sen the tech sector is kind
of giving banks a run for their money
but but historically um the influence of
sitting down with you know president
obama or president trump or whoever from
a major banker like jp morgan chase's
chairman and ceo jamie dimon really does
have a lot of clout and also the media
it has cloud on the other side so they
can influence washington through
influencing business media and the
narrative of what banks do and why
they're needed
even if they do criminal things um and
why they need to be maintained in their
in their current form
now nomie prince you come from that side
of the equation as well don't you yeah
so when enron was happening i was at
that time i was i was managing director
of goldman sachs and i i was working i i
had a team that created um what were
called credit derivatives which were
effectively bets on whether companies or
any sorts of loans whether they were
attached to mortgages or anything else
would default um basically that's what
a credit derivative is it's like i bet
you that you'll be able to either pay
off your loan or not be able to pay off
your loan or if you're a company you
either are able to pay off the debt that
you borrowed in the public markets or
from banks or you're not and then i kind
of bet on that and i offset that bet
with someone else who's willing to take
the other side um or with insurance
companies that ensure
this bet or this insurance i'm taking
out on the other side to to make this
bet but but they were much more
convoluted than that um ultimately as as
we found out in the subprime mortgage
crisis um and the aftermath in the
financial crisis but but i created um at
goldman and at bear stearns as well
where i ran an analytics department for
seven years during
a little more than seven years during
the 90s
through for bear stearns the creations
that could enable these types of credit
derivatives to be used for
investors for companies in large
quantities mixed and matched together so
all the analytics for that i was very
much involved in throughout my career on
wall street and when i left and actually
wrote this in other people's money i
think towards the end of that book i i
said
that and i wrote that credit derivatives
and cdos which to get real technical on
a sunday
and then i'll go on
credit uh collateralized debt
obligations collateralize just mean i
put a bunch of stuff together and i bet
against that also just in layman's terms
um
they were something that i said we
should watch because they'll be at the
crux of the next financial crisis
that's partly because i i saw where they
were going i saw the sort of junk that
was being put inside of them and that
still is
and that
then they were very small they're a very
small part of the market and they were
very much
in fashion because they could make so
much money for banks like goldman sachs
or banks like bear stearns
and then ultimately they became the crux
of a financial implosion years later
were you good at your job
yes i was good at my job and that i was
um i was a quantitative analyst
throughout my career on wall street i
started as a programmer um at the chase
manhattan bank in the 80s from having
gotten a degree in math um and that's
basically trying to get a job and work
in new york city and uh those those
sorts of banks were hiring and so from
the beginning of
of um of derivatives of looking at
aggregating different types of financial
securities looking at the math looking
at the programming um i did that stuff
from the sort of
very initial level um in in the 80s to
when i ultimately left in 2002 but what
i also did and one of the reasons i left
wall street was it was very important
when i was creating analytics or
directing my team
as i was building them in the different
places i worked to to
to analyze the downside to make sure
that if a sales person was selling a
product for which we were doing
analytics
they were also explaining
what the risks were in that product
and what began happening was
as
things got more voracious and more
competitive and there was more money in
these more esoteric products this idea
of talking to clients about risk or or
funding
risk analytics within the company
and just like the budget in washington
you know this money goes for this this
money goes for that um that happens in
in in banks as well
um it wasn't kind of considered a
priority it was sort of down considered
um and i had more and more of a problem
just morally on that um because it just
didn't yeah it's one thing to to create
something and there's risk attached to
it and
and if someone understands the risk to
be involved but if the risk is either a
ultimately on the public but but b
can't be explained
properly um then then that's a bigger
problem and that's where i started to
divide out from wall street and
ultimately become a journalist and an
author oh and you write about 911 and
the impact that had on you
yeah so that was really the breaking
point um i think for a lot of us in new
york i mean i was working at goldman
sachs at the time um very close to where
the towers
had been and in fact that morning
i had a corner office actually on on a
high floor at goldman sachs um
and
the actual planes
went
by my office now when the first plane
went nobody
nobody really noticed that nobody on the
news noticed that i mean it just sort of
happened but we were sort of in the
flight path um but then once all the
sort of tickers and debris and smoke
started accumulating very quickly
upwards and it started to be covered on
the news and the second plane came by
that that plane we noticed that plane
came came very close now at the time
that moment of impact obviously none of
us knew
it was
a terrorist attack but but what we did
what did happen was everything got very
chaotic very quickly um internally we
were actually supposed to go to an off
site to talk about credit derivatives
and all our teams have flown in from
around the world the night before and
we're supposed to go off somewhere and
sort of like you know do a jekyll island
but basically the kind of thing that
happens all the time in banking and just
be somewhere else obviously we couldn't
and my clarity moment was when one of
the people from sort of a major person
in the department said you know well
maybe if we leave now we can beat the
traffic out of manhattan and it was like
dude there's there's like no there's
something really big happening here like
it's not about you know that right now
but then ultimately those next few days
i spent a lot of time just thinking
about where i was at where my head was
at where life was i wound up
volunteering to help at the armory
instead of going into work
at goldman a few days afterwards to try
and match items with with people as they
were coming in and just sort of help
volunteer to do that whereas we were
supposed to be at work and so there was
all these moments of of just um
priorities
in terms of what's happening in the
industry in life life in general and so
yes that was a very big pivot point for
me and i wound up resigning
a few months after that
from it takes a pillage nomi prince
writes
unless you've been embraced into the
bosom of goldman sachs even for a brief
spate of time
it's hard to fully grasp its culture of
excellence
it's like harvard the new york times the
senate and the new york yankees all
rolled into one
once you drink the kool-aid and manage
not to spit it out you really begin to
think you're better than everyone else
i wrote that
yeah um
the
so first of all when i was interviewed
um for goldman as as people were um it's
it's a very long process um
i was working in bear stearns in london
at the time um i was sought out by
goldman uh to come to new york and and
do credit related products with them and
through this nine-month interviewing
process there was partners that you know
i met when they were in london you know
i was out in new york i mean it's all
it's it's a rigorous
um you know getting through of a sort of
totem pole up through
you know the very senior levels of the
company and so all along the way
um there's this idea not that we didn't
know goldman sachs had this aura in in
the industry of being
um you know so the mana of wall street
or the mana of like banking because of
how it just
presented itself you know and so the
idea of the interview process kind of
manifested that like if you get through
this
hurdle and you get through this hurdle
you get through this hurdle it's almost
like this makes you you know if we like
you more this this makes you better and
it's kind of like a weird cultural
indoctrination just just from the
beginning
and once you get through
that um i remember i was standing on one
of the trading floors for one of the
sort of later interviews and i was um
being interviewed by lord blankfein who
became the ceo of goldman sachs and i
sort of walked me out after we were
chatting to the the trading floor and he
kind of does one of these
and he says
this is not bear stearns
in other words like we are just so much
better than bear stearns which is where
i was at um you know this is goldman
sachs and it was it was that kind of um
aura and that moment of you know
presentation of who we are um and the
idea of that culture of excellence um
and and that's what there's there's a
book about um as well that was written
um not too long after i was there about
goldman's culture of excellence is
something that's discussed internally
they consider it that's the word they
use it's it's considered a culture of
excellence and if you are
like
them um sort of moving up the the sort
of
ladder then you are called a culture
carrier
it's just a thing
um at least when i was there and so this
idea of of being one of us
um and then doing your job
but then your job is about being one of
us is is very sort of self um enforcing
um and that's what i mean by that that
there's there's a very strong
sense of we are really great if you're
here you're really great but only if you
behave like us and if you don't maybe
you don't belong here
what do they do
[Laughter]
well will they like um
any of the sort of more marquee
investment banks do a few major things
um they
put banks together they put companies
together they're they're investment
banking um advisors so they they find
acquirers of companies and they they
basically find companies that want to be
acquired and they
work out the details and and for working
out the details a couple of things fall
out one thing that falls out
is
a lot of fees
another thing that falls out of that
deal are
the ability to potentially issue bonds
on behalf of that new company or on
behalf of one of the companies involved
so that they can raise money to either
go on with the next part of their
business or to
buy each other
they can issue shares they can issue new
shares of stock to to do that um and
then ultimately once companies are
already merged together or they already
exist without having been merged they're
just corporate clients
they can work on issuing stocks they can
trade those stocks they can work on
issuing bonds they can trade those bonds
and they can effectively create
sort of financial
powers for their clients that they take
cuts of all along the way either through
the initial creation of bonds or stocks
or a deal or through trading it
in something called the secondary market
along the way so they can kind of be on
both sides
of the initial
entry of something new to
trading something that's already in
existence
in your newest book collusion
you write
that much of the 20th century belonged
to wall street
the 21st century now belongs to the
central banks
right so along the way
of the 20th century you know as we
talked about that the influence through
through wars through crises through
economic policy through trade agreements
through all sorts of other things was
very much a sort of symbiotic
conversation a relationship that
occurred between
administrations presidencies and the
major banks
of the country so your jpmorgan morgan
chase citigroup bank of america goldman
sachs morgan stanley and so forth
as we went into this
uh century not so much the beginning of
it but sort of the last decade and
moving forward central banks stepped in
to act as the financers
for everything the banks were doing so
when the crisis happened
in 2008
the fed did this major pivot the federal
reserve the main central bank of the us
did a major pivot and said
well
banks don't trust each other right now
they just created a crisis
number one but number two they don't
trust each other even let alone feel
compelled to give money to like the
small businesses or to individuals at at
the rates we're ultimately going to give
them which is zero um but but into the
crisis we we will come in and help them
and we will create or fabricate money
electronically in order to provide them
with credit
um because we can
but
what happened was they didn't just do it
a little bit
they took a situation the federal
reserve in conjunction with the treasury
department and major bankers at the time
and they took something that was
considered to be an emergency i what was
going on in the fall of 2008
when there was
you know basically a complete crisis of
confidence in the banking system
inside it and externally related to it
and they said we're just going to dump
tons and tons of money into the system
to make it right we're going to do it as
an emergency basis first we're going to
give banks loans we're going to give
them low rates so they can basically get
money from us at nothing
and we're going to buy ultimately bonds
from them
that no one else wants in order to give
them more cash something called
quantitative easing
in order for them to continue to operate
so this this entire shift from the banks
having a lot of this major influence
financially relative to washington to
say the fed having it was because the
fed had the money like all of a sudden
it wasn't just the banks that had the
money and had the ability to raise money
in private markets historically or in
public markets and plus so much of
people's deposits on which they could do
more uh financial activities with
all of a sudden there's this extra
body
it had been there all the time it had
been created
ultimately over you know 100 years or so
before that to provide banks help when
they needed it but it went into
overdrive and it wasn't just the federal
reserve as i talked about in collusion
it was a federal reserve it was the
european central bank the bank of japan
sort of on to that ultimately people's
bank of china all the major banks in
different ways throughout the world
decided to find ways to electronically
fabricate money to put into their
systems
um
and then they're still going
so so this thing that was an emergency
and considered to be an emergency back
in 2008 has become policy
and it's become monetary policy and even
though people don't really think of it
this way it's it's our economic policy
it's there's this this this this body
that can create
funds when necessary and that has no
legal cap
to how much they can create there's a
cap in terms of how much conversation
they might have about how much they've
created or what public opinion might be
or what political opinion might be but
there's no legal cap
to what
any of these central banks can create
electronically in the guise of helping
the financial system or in the guise of
helping the general economy and that's
why they have so much more power now
than they had before because they now
know this
um and and in different ways over the
last years decade plus since the
financial crisis that is really how they
operate so whoever's heading the federal
reserve whoever's heading the european
central bank the institutions themselves
are now sort of superseding even their
ability and and what they may want to do
by the virtual power
of being to create able to create so
much money
when they want to
here's the warning from collusion
the fed and its allies have created a
shaky monetary system that will collapse
without their manipulation
central bankers for all their meetings
and posh locales the world over
have no plan b to reverse or alter
course without causing massive damage
and financial pain
to billions of people yes
um so
what's happened and actually we can even
see this with with since since i wrote
the book but but recently um our federal
reserve had an about face in its policy
right so
just just going back really quickly to
what central banks do um
are one of the things they do is they
they
create a level for
interest rates and by virtue of that
level of interest rates that's what
banks basically receive um that's that's
the interest that banks have to pay in
order to receive that money so when the
fed put rates down at zero percent in
the end of 2008 and kept them there
through december 2015 they were
basically saying sort of one of our
tools
is to be able to make sure that the cost
of money over a three month period is is
negligible to
to banks
from 2015 to the end of 2018
incrementally they raise the cost of
that money they raised interest rates
once
by just 25 basis points a quarter of one
percent in 2015 and then they waited a
whole year because the markets didn't
like that 2016 was all about turbulence
in the beginning after the fed just
raised their rates after seven years of
being at zero by a quarter of one
percent by like nothing by the smallest
amount of margin it could possibly raise
rates by
um
and so then they stopped for a year and
they didn't raise rates again until the
end of
2016 and december 2016 by another 25
basis points and then they did some more
in 2017 and more in 2018 but always with
an eye to seeing whether the financial
system the markets themselves
would be okay with that and what is them
being okay with that that means not
having like massive sort of cratery down
turns in the market
um
this year
on january 3rd after there was a fourth
rate hike last year
which was in december 2018
the markets opened really upset
and banks were really upset and as it
turns out there were meetings with
senior bankers and the fed at the end of
december as well sort of going into what
became an about-face about face was the
u.s fed saying you know what
we're just going to hold back so first
it was just some language different
central bank leaders from the different
parts of the 12 bank central reserve
system sort of started popping up saying
well maybe the economy is too slow
maybe we shouldn't you know tighten too
much things started being said um and
then a couple weeks ago the main policy
came out that like you know we're not
raising rates at all this year at all
and maybe not even until 2020.
and the reason for that is considered to
be because the economy is slowing
and if you raise rates or increase the
cost of money too much you choke off the
ability of that economy to get its funds
the reality is that many times during
this 10-year period the economy is doing
a lot worse than it's been doing
recently and they've still kept rates
low the difference now
is that the markets have gotten upset
again
and so january 3rd was a negative day
since then we've seen a massive rally in
the stock market because of the fed's
about-face
because it wasn't just the fed that
about faced it was all the central banks
around the world who were worried that
if the fed didn't about face
they would have to tighten money they
would have to make money more expensive
they would have to stop buying assets in
their markets to keep the level of
finance
up and the cost of money down
and then they were like okay we're gonna
we're gonna just breathe a sigh of
relief now because the fed's not gonna
do it we definitely don't have to worry
about it and that's why some of their
markets have rallied as well
so there is this dislocation between
economies and markets if the fed were
truly and other central banks were truly
you know getting back to what i what i
said we're truly to say all right well
we're going to normalize rates we're
going to reduce the size
of our books or the amount of money we
put into the market and we're going to
basically sell the assets we bought for
that money and take the money back
there would be
absolute
financial crisis throughout the entire
banking systems of all these major
countries and the stock market and and
that's not like
some you know crazy statement that
doesn't come from the actual data that
that's just looking upon what happens
when money gets too tight too quickly
and the immediate reaction
of the stock market which is a place
where money moves very quickly in and
out so the reactions there are very
indicative of the reactions that are
happening throughout corporations and
banks throughout the world as well
so if you don't understand exactly what
nomi prinz is talking about and need a
refresher the nice thing about your
books is you put in glossaries and casts
of characters as you call them yes
which is very important good afternoon
this is book tv's monthly in-depth
program our guest this month is author
and financial journalist nomie prinz her
first book came out in 2004 after she
left goldman sachs and it's called other
people's money the corporate mugging of
america her next book came out in 06
jacked how conservatives in quotes are
picking your pocket whether you voted
for them or not
the trial came out in 2008 but it was
written by somebody named
natalia prentice who is that yeah that
was my alter ego actually that book it
was um the trail it was a thriller it
was a financial thriller because what i
decided to do when i left goldman
initially
was to
well kind of do a john grisham with
respect
but basically write about my industry
from the standpoint of something that
was palatable um and so actually that
book um i wrote as i was leaving goldman
and it came out later and i so i took
another name because i just kind of done
that to begin with just in case it was
too close to home and one of the things
about that book now that you have
mentioned it and just recalling i talk
about a character um who was the head of
a company that was kind of equivalent to
goldman i think i called it silverman
very very very loosely loosely veiled
and um
how that character ultimately became the
vice president of the united states and
and in fact it was kind of based on hank
paulson who became the treasury
secretary of the united states um later
but it wasn't it wasn't far off from
that so i i i basically was using that
name for for that purpose
it takes a pillage 2009 an epic tale of
power deceit
and untold trillions black tuesday
another novel came out in 2011 her two
most recent books all the president's
bankers the hidden alliances that drive
american power 2014 and her most recent
is collusion how central bankers rigged
the world this is your chance to talk
with nomi prinz here are the numbers
202-748-8200 if you live in the east or
central time zones 202-748-8201
for those of you in the mountain and
western time zones
if you cannot get through on the phone
lines and still want to make a comment
we're going to cycle through our social
media sites as well
twitter facebook and email all available
to you we monitor those as well
so nomi prinz
what
now that we have this 100 year history
100 plus year history that you've
written about
what what has there been a cost to the
taxpayer
there has been a cost the tax paper
payer also also the voter
um because
when you talk about you know a major
banker who can influence policy and
ultimately um for example in the case of
of jpmorgan chase um jamie dimon was
someone who was on uh the new york fed
board he was a class a director at the
new york fed board of goldman
no he was actually had a jp morgan chase
so jamie dimon so he happened to have
been in the height of the financial
crisis when it first occurred also a
director at the new york fed which is
the wall street located fed of this
12-member reserve system but he was one
of the people along with hank paulson
who at that time was treasury secretary
but who had been when when i came into
goldman the ceo and chairman of goldman
sachs um you know tim geithner who had a
lot of relationships ultimately came in
but he was a new york fed president at
the time and then became the treasury
secretary under obama at the turn of the
year after that crisis so you have all
these individuals
who effectively have the ability to
direct
policy and money coming out of
washington
to their own institutions which are
public institutions you know these are
banks that trade on you know stock
exchanges they're monitored supposedly
by the federal reserve because one of
their day jobs is to be the regulatory
sort of answer the oversight body to
these banks
they're they're monitored and yet their
individuals have such a tight
relationship with
the central political powers of the
country that they are able to get money
effectively to themselves when they need
it and far greater figures than
individuals
are able to galvanize to do that as a
result money goes from
taxpayers to
benefit them and not just when there's a
crisis
but even from the standpoint of for
example
a legal act called the glass-steagall
act which was repealed in 1999 it had
been in place since 1933 specifically to
protect the depositors and the taxpaying
public and voters from any kind of weird
esoteric products or speculation that
banks could do banks could choose to bet
on all sorts of stuff but if they lost
those bets it was on them it was on
their shareholders it was on their
private partners however they were
structured to repay it it wasn't on the
government it wasn't on people
that was repealed in 1999 so all of a
sudden you had this merging of people's
deposits people's cash people's
mortgages into institutions that also
could do all sorts of stuff with that
do badly with it bet wrong and then come
to the government for help the fact that
they had all these deposits
that they could say well we have them
you know atm machines aren't going to
work people aren't going to get their
money back in this crisis unless you
give us all these other things
meant a different way of taking money
from depositors or taxpayers because
they influenced the policy that allowed
them to have all those deposits
so on multiple levels they're they're
they're extracting um by their influence
and when things go wrong and
to remove rules surrounding their their
businesses from
taxpayers um into their own pockets
so jim walsh
tweets in to you
could you explain how someone so
brilliant and economically astute
you
supports an economic system that always
fails at tremendous human and economic
cost
or devol dissolves into a dictatorship
she supports progressivism socialism is
that true are you a socialist
i support certain socialist policies
because
if we think about how
economics
divides
into the needs of society in other words
how money that comes from
society
helps society and how governments are
used to appropriate those funds i think
about things like like how expensive
health care is for for people in this
country
i think about how expensive it is for a
student to go to university
and to come out with 50 60 70 000 worth
of debt which means they can't
ultimately be the kind of participant in
our economy that they could have been
without so much debt when i went to
school
i went i started out in in public
schools and i went to a community
college and then i ultimately went to a
state college and then i went to private
to nyu for all my education but i paid
for
all of it along the way
and i could pay for all of it along the
way because what i was earning by
working um was enough to allow me to
afford courses and books and and rents
on tiny places at the time
and and now that that's an impossibility
so when i look at the economy as a whole
and think okay do we think it's better
for an economy to to be more level for
people for more people in order for them
to contribute
foundationally throughout most parts of
the economy in an easier way
and i think about how we also have
firefighters and now we have post
offices and how we have police officers
and a whole host of elements of our
society that are meant to help more of
society than just their shareholders or
just their banking institutions so i
look at it from the standpoint of
a healthy society that's healthy
economically
and educationally and and physically and
and they're protected um
defense is another um sort of level of
our society which has a lot of money um
that goes into it um and supposedly to
protect everyone protect the country um
all of those things to me are social
good
and
what i support from the economic
standpoint and financially is for actors
within that not to risk
the country's financial health and be
bailed out to the extent that they were
by
the country by taxpayers or helped to
the extent that they've been by the
federal reserve
so
i look at an economy as as being
holistic in in that respect
so
in today's current political environment
is capitalism at a tipping point
i think in general we're a capitalist
nation i mean we
we do strive as as a nation to
do um business activities that that
create profits and and those profits go
in different ways um either to the
people involved in creating them or to
society or to tax or to people's futures
i don't think that's going away but i i
do think
that
using wall street as an example and
using the financial crisis as an example
and using the fact that
our federal reserve still has four
trillion dollars of assets on our books
after what isn't an emergency situation
we should think anymore since it
happened in 2008 and it's still
subsidizing wall street and subsidizing
larger banks those are tremendous sums
of money and so i think that a
healthy capital capitalism
has to
recognize that putting too much money in
one place where that one place has
actually been a cost to the general
financial system or to general um the
general economy is is not necessarily a
good decision
um and so i think it needs to be more
regulated i think we have rules in place
that that do that that were ignored
um
into the the collapse that we're still
sort of reeling from in terms of these
policies um and i think that those need
to be reinvigorated and i think we need
to protect everyone
now before we go to calls finally um
the fed is in your view a fed type
bank necessary
is question number one and then i'll
follow up with question number two
um
i think what the fed does
in terms of providing so much subsidy to
so many banks is not necessary
i think the fact that the fed can sort
of raise or lower interest rates in
terms of a monetary policy element is
something that could equally be done
within a treasury department i think
that
the fact that the fed is structured in a
way
that allows
the private members of that bank which
is which is how it's structured the fed
ultimately
does provide credit and does take
meetings with the heads of wall street
firms and stuff because they are the
primary shareholders in the fed and
they're the historic shareholders in the
fed they created um the fed so wherever
the fed is today um
there's a major flaw
in how it was created and how it exists
which is that it exists ultimately um to
benefit its members and it says it
exists to member uh to help greater the
greater economy and sort of the greater
public but the reality is
if you look at the actions um they're
very visceral when it hap when there's a
situation where a wall street large
institution is in trouble
or there's a necessity to help a gold
miner to help a j.p morgan chase or to
help someone who has an institution that
is part of the history and the fabric of
how the fed was created has benefited
from how the fed is created and
continues to benefit from this sort of
implicit subsidy that not just the fed
but all of the central banks provide to
the largest banks in their respective
countries
and i think that's a flaw
are the u.s and the china central banks
in your view colluding
okay so this is a very interesting
question because
the major collusion i talk about in the
book had to do with predominantly the g7
countries and what was interesting after
the financial crisis was that um the
methods that they were using the timing
of of quantitative easing of reducing
their rates of putting money um to swap
between them to help make sure that
currencies were moving back and forth
between the central banks and ultimately
to the banks of the major banks in their
respective countries because they work
with each other across borders all of
that happened with phone calls with
documents with things i have in the book
between the sort of major countries
where china comes in where the people's
bank of china comes in is that they
actually were quite critical of this
process from the beginning and it's kind
of fascinating because one of the major
ways i believe that china became such a
tremendous economic superpower
in the decades since the financial
crisis is that initially they were very
public about being critical of the fed's
policy that if you create too much money
too quickly if you subsidize a system
ultimately that system can't sustain
itself however in recent years the
people's bank of china has also been
creating their own sort of quantitative
easing the difference between what
happens in china and what happens with
the fed so they're not so much colluding
but they're acting in sort of opposition
to in in a world where
if money's cheap in one place and we
have sort of an international capital
globalized system it's going to be cheap
somewhere else people's bank of china
has come in with their own methods but
what they do is they inject them sort of
directly into um
sort of more growth strategies
throughout their country so they'll
actually direct some of the money that
they create into say infrastructure
building
into companies that create higher speed
railroads or companies that finance them
and so forth which we don't
so they have a different just twist
so it's not so much collusion it's more
sort of the the the antithesis but the
result is still creating money
it's just directed in different ways in
the us and in china right now
nomi prince is our guest in sisi is in
portland oregon go ahead cece
hi um i have a comment and a question
um
you know and the comment is within the
context of the person
who makes fifty thousand dollars a year
and has a
401k
this whole
what you've been describing to me
um sounds like um
that there's no free hand you know as
adam smith's theory and the freehand
laissez-faire that this is really
gambling that the stock market in wall
street is the bookmaker like in vegas
and they're playing around with our
money
gambling i just see it as gambling i
mean i know it there's no you know way
for us it seems to make money or to
advance um as just a fifty thousand
dollar a year for a 1k person you know
without having it in there but
essentially that the
rules are
you know regular working public 50 000 a
year put all your money in the stock
market and then the people that who are
managing the stock market the wealthy
people they don't leave their money in
the stock market they move it in and out
constantly with all these reports and
they tell the the person with the 401k
making 50 000 a year just leave it in
there because that's the money in my
mind that they're playing around with
all right cece we're going to get a
response to that are you invested in
these markets
via a retirement account or any other
method
i i am and so what i want to know is
tell me why this isn't gambling
you know and
and how it is
um that the person making fifty thousand
dollars a year
is is post is supposed to trust the
system and uh finally um is there such
thing as the freehand of the market
anymore is that a myth thank you ma'am
very good question yeah those are
excellent questions cc i mean because
well for a number of reasons one i i
think your question really um gets to
the core of so many
millions of people in this country
because the reality is only about
10 percent of the country owns 90
percent of the stocks in the u.s stock
market so even
someone like you who has an investment
through your 401k plan in the stock
market the reality is that it is the
people that that are wealthier that have
accumulated more stock that also
ultimately um get the the benefits of
the stock market going up in in
significantly more ways when they're in
it than than you would see um the reason
um it is gambling um is because
um and it's it's rigged gambling in a
way because these institutions you know
whether they're um hedge funds or
whether they're brokers that um and you
should check this on your 401k plan
everyone should um who make a money make
money for for moving um what's in your
401k around so some 401k plans are
actively managed it means that brokers
are moving them around they get fees for
for trading and not necessarily for
performance and that comes out of your
retirement that comes out of the lump
sum that's left at the end of the day
that that's something to take a look at
but but those institutions that do that
and those institutions that manage money
and the fact that there is this
relationship between
wall street institutions that get
this access to to cheaper rates and get
access to federal reserve policy and
influence
the policy means they're also kind of
influencing the stock market so from
their perspective if they're betting on
the stock market and i am using the term
betting um as you view the term gambling
um they they also have a sense for
whether um it's gonna
go up or down more so than you might for
a number of reasons one is they have the
volume
so they can see how much volume is going
in or out um they also have the ability
when things go down too much to go to
the you know the federal reserve and and
say look you know there are some
problems going on here or or look at our
books or you know we could have credit
issues going forward and sort of ease
money a little bit and then that money
goes back into the stock market the
reason the stock market rises so quickly
in that manner
is because it's easy to accumulate money
into and it's easy
for money to come out with it which also
makes it a very good haven for betting
that's not to say there are companies in
there that have real value
and that aren't producing things for the
country and aren't hiring people in the
country and are providing input into the
economy um and and and buying shares in
those stocks isn't necessarily um a
gamble that's actually investing in in
the growth of that company but where the
gambling comes in is how they're all
um ultimately that their stocks are are
related to money that's coming in from
an outside source so getting to the adam
smith idea you know sort of a free hand
the reality is right now and
particularly um in the last year since
the financial crisis this sort of
external artificial injection of money
into the financial system that then gets
borrowed against and leveraged into
moving stocks up moving real estate up
for those that have that money at the
top that receive the bulk of that wealth
back and then reposition it into the
market and move it up even further
that
connotes sort of a lack of transparency
and a lack of sort of a full
sort of free market element and what it
does is it shows that there's this
artificial
stimulus to the market
which which has continued to drive it if
you look at the relationship between
bouts of quantitative easing of the fed
or other central banks buying
assets in their countries you'll see
that those are days in which their stock
markets tend to go up why there's just
more money coming in artificially into
the system and it lifts it up
scott's in new york city you're on with
author nomie prince scott
hi naomi i wanted to uh talk to you
about an idea i have been a set of ideas
i've been developing recently and that
is if you were to construct a global
wealth tax
where the 0.1 percent of the wealthy the
large corporations and the large
foundations
had to pay seven percent a year
if they do not pay with bank loans
but they only have to pay three percent
a year if they do pay with bank loans
then obviously to save 400 basis points
on their wealth all these guys would pay
with bank loans
and the banks would get two sets of fees
first they'd be able to charge fees to
the wealthy for uh providing the loans
and then a second set of fees is the
banks would package
the loans into wealth tax collateralized
loan obligation bonds
and the bond buyers would pay a fee for
the packaging
so the banks the wealth tax if you
constructed it that way the banks could
make 200 billion to 600 billion dollars
a year
for the 10 trillion dollars a year plus
in wealth tax money
and since you were talking earlier about
how powerful the bank lobby is and since
this would be the most profitable event
in the history of the banking industry
uh
the bank lobby would be the most
ferocious proponent for the global
wealth tax so scott do you work in the
financial industry
yeah i was a i'm a retired jp morgan
banker and i was a hedge fund banker
and i'm uh i'm an alumnus from columbia
university i'm i was a math mathematics
and what made you come up with this
formula what was the impetus
so i've been thinking about this a long
time and my uh so my i lived with this
woman for 11 years who graduated second
or class from columbia and then she
works at a big law firm
and she there was that one of her
clients went years and years and years
without paying his taxes
and she he's a billionaire guy and she
um
she arranged a 100 million dollar loan
for him to pay his taxes
and of course i look at twitter all the
time and i see these right wing guys are
saying hey you can't have a wealth tax
because all these rich guys will have to
liquidate all their assets
and uh so you know i would always
respond look if you think these guys if
you think a guy worth two billion
dollars can't get a bank loan at low
interest to pay his wealth tax i mean
then you just don't know you have no
concept of reality all right we're going
to have to leave it there scott know me
prince what did you hear
um so scott that that's interesting
because um you know the last thing you
said i'll just start with that it is
true that someone who has you know such
an extreme amount of wealth should be
able to not just figure out how to you
know sort of borrow cheaply in order to
pay a tax but but also just in general
um if there were a tax that was sort of
more related to their actual wealth as
opposed to um you know sort of
leveraging that wealth then you know
they they could easily um figure out how
to make extra money in order to sort of
cover their tax anyway whether they're
borrowing to do it or whether that's
just you know siphoning a portion of
what they have and just making more so i
i agree with you that you know someone
in that position
and this actually almost relates to
sisi's comment before you know the more
wealth you have
the less you'll feel
a tax that's true and if a wealth tax
were created in such a way that
it was connected to banks being able to
manufacture or to securitize um as you
mentioned to basically aggregate loans
that go to um institutions or
individuals from which they can pay
their wealth tax um yes that would be
something that would be an attractive
way for them to buy into a wealth tax
and also make money out of it i i agree
with that on the other hand i think if
we're going to have
a wealth tax we should look at it um
as as more of a sort of speculation tax
in that it should be related to sort of
accumulated wealth you know just just
period and yes that is hard to um to
find uh a way to purely get to from a
sort of forensic accounting perspective
um but the idea would be if we're
actually um
taxing say transactions or speculative
transactions or or buying a piece of a
clo or selling a piece of a clo at a
certain higher level than say a capital
gains tax
that would be a way to sort of take some
of that money
back into the system um and and then and
then use it for you know sort of other
things that might be more beneficial
jay's in asheville north carolina good
afternoon jay
good afternoon thank you for taking my
call i have a question for your guests
about
it's relatively simple question
about these rating agencies like moody
now prior to the
when the bottom fell out of the tub in
2008
all these wall street mouth breathers
were taking these so-called
mortgage-backed securities
to places like moody's
who stamped every single one of them
triple a absolutely absolutely brill
can't lose
i mean any damn fool knows that there's
so much so much commercial paper
that's going to qualify as that
that any of these people at these rating
agencies that that
stamped all this toilet paper triple a
or any of them ever jailed or prosecuted
jay before we get an answer uh were you
affected by the 2008 crisis
no not at all i was lucky thank you sir
know me prince thanks for that question
jay and and and and good that you
weren't um
yeah well first of all um the way the
rating agencies work as as you mentioned
is that they they get paid um based on
what what they're rating um and the
information that they get that goes into
securities that they're rating
tends to come from the institutions that
want these securities rated now they
should also have independent sources and
in some cases they do but the reality is
the payment relationship um has been
that
a bank who wants
a security rated
goes to moody's or s p and so forth they
stamp it they get paid by that bank for
that relationship and for that stamping
and and it goes into the market um and
and that was definitely one of the one
of the main problems um at the crux of
the financial crisis because not only
did banks have um bad loans coming in
already and i just you know because you
you know we're talking about this i just
want to say just just from someone who
yeah programmed that the smallest
details of things throughout my career
at wall street banks have information
coming in all the time they know
immediately if a loan isn't going to pay
or if it's in delinquency or if it's in
default that they know exactly what to
pick and and what happened was and what
still happens um today in creating these
collateralized securities where where
the collateral um you know are the loans
um at the time the collateral were
mortgage loans is that banks are just
picking enough bad loans to add to the
good loans to get the good rating on the
entire package but to give them enough
money
because the bad loans generally are
paying a higher interest before they go
bad than the good loans we're paying
that's why they're subprime their their
their rates are higher uh to the
borrower um and so they're getting juice
out of that entire beginning process of
creating a loan what their the security
they're showing it to the more to the
rating agency and the rating in hc is
rating that high and then what happens
is
institutions who only are supposed to
buy aaa rated securities are like cool
we're going to buy a triple a related
security and it's going to give us more
return than another kind of like a
treasury bond that's also aaa rated
that's great we'll buy as much as we can
and what else happened during the
financial crisis which made it worse is
they would borrow money from the same
banks creating these securities
in order to buy them so now these
institutions that could only buy aaa are
buying something that's labeled triple a
that really isn't and they're also
borrowing money because they have a aaa
against the aaa thing they just bought
which they also have to pay back so you
multiply that a number of times it's
like going down to vegas and every time
you lose 100 bucks on blackjack someone
else lends you 100 bucks you think great
i have another 100 bucks to play but in
fact you actually ultimately have to go
bust or repay everyone back
that's still the situation today except
for the fact that the rating agencies
now
um
tend to be rating securities that have
corporate loans in them
as opposed to more of those mortgage
loans or individual borrowers so what's
now happened
in the year since the financial crisis
is because the cost of money was so low
and companies were able to borrow or to
leverage themselves so much so cheaply
if any of those go bust it will create a
default
if their loans are packaged somewhere
else and rated high
and then they default
then that package is going to decrease
in value very quickly again so we're
kind of in that situation again with
rating agencies but but to your other
point no nobody in rating agencies went
to jail nobody in um you know a ceo
running any of the institutions despite
the billions of dollars they paid in
fines to the department of justice in
the sec have gone to jail four frauds um
and you know you have to go back to my
first book you know people like ken lay
who ran
enron were were sent to jail but but not
not any of the people running the the
banking institutions involved in this
process
steve's in anchorage alaska hi steve
hello thank you for taking my call
i very much appreciate having the
opportunity to hear miss prince today
my call is two part i'd like to first of
all go back to the point that you made
that about the relationship
between the social goods that provide
the benefits to the society and the
relationship of the economic system
it should be fundamentally a position to
provide those
those services
in that context
i'm wondering about the social order in
which it is
by law and judicial decision
the obligation fiduciary obligation of
corporations to make solely make profit
for their shareholders
and the need to fundamentally re-change
remake that particular proposition
and let me link that to a second
uh related proposition which is
if you're familiar with the uh
governance of ghana you may recognize a
man named jerry rollins
jerry rollins was the leader of the
ghanaian air force
who uh
carried off a coup after watching years
and years of elite and corporate
corruption deflecting monies away from
the basic social goods for the society
after assuming power he passed a law
entitled economic sabotage
and with those laws he indicted and
found guilty those previous uh owners
why should we not have economic sabotage
laws associated with the manner in which
our economic
institutions function thank you steve
we're going to leave it there
know me prince um so steve going back to
what i was saying before and i i don't
know all the ins and outs of what
happened in ghana but but from what what
you're saying and from your question um
again the the institutions that were
involved in the financial crisis just to
look at our most recent example of of
just mass fraud um to which some of them
um admitted or settled um to the tune of
multi billions of dollars and and and
for which this fraud still continues you
know look at a bank like um wells fargo
where you know after the financial
crisis after paying tens of billions of
dollars worth of settlements for various
mortgage related and other types of of
uh mis statements and and fraud um they
they went about creating fake accounts
for their real customers and then charge
those real customers fees on those fake
accounts which were ultimately uh
discovered to be fake but in the
meantime those people um you know might
just be on the edge of their paychecks
for that month or like 80 of the country
is living paycheck to paycheck and it
means something um to have fees or to
have a credit score go against you or
whatever it might be because a bank is
basically you know committing fraud and
stealing from you
these are all things that none of us
should be proud of economically and we
shouldn't subsidize institutions that
are doing this and we should have real
individuals
made to be responsible and liable and if
there's jail time for those crimes and
they're tried
and and it's discovered that they're
guilty that that should be done because
the net results particularly the
financial system of having um
such a link to
so many subsidies or being able to pay
fines so easily because of the laws that
enable them to function as they're
currently functioning without having
real accountability
is ultimately a detriment on multiple
levels of society because the things
that they do to society affect
incrementally
so many people
in our society and in our economy so so
i agree we need to have a better way of
of making them legally responsible and
enforcing laws and creating laws that
don't allow these things to happen or at
least have regulators more attuned to
what's going on as it's going on
and not after the damage has been done
to individuals
it was in 2009 that it takes a pillage
came out nomi prinz appeared on our
afterwards program
and she was interviewed by this
gentleman
i remember i'm a member of the budget
committee now
and we had hank paulson in a couple of
years ago and i said mr paulson back in
my state of vermont around this country
the middle class is in a whole lot of
trouble people are really struggling
people
losing their jobs their income is going
down there's a growing gap between the
very rich and everybody else
what's your sense of the economy and he
said oh the economy is doing really good
and year after year and this is really
astounding and a bit aggravating year
after year we heard from the bush
administration that from their
perspective the economy was doing great
now
explain to me how they could believe the
economy was doing great
when the middle class was collapsing and
we were getting closer and closer and
closer to the edge of a major global
financial crisis because for them it was
great and that's the problem
nomi prince what's your relationship
with senator sanders
um well since um since i was on the show
which was where the first time um that i
met senator sanders was actually was was
um here at c-span for that interview
i subsequently served on his federal
reserve advisory council which was a
bipartisan
council
to take a look at or at least to talk to
the fed at the time about more
transparency
in terms of what they were doing because
at that time they were now subsidizing
the banks um in a tremendous way
and trying to sort of influence them to
actually use our limited influence to
influence them to think about these
matters and where they could lead
going forward in in a better way
i've also contributed to recently
he had a bill out at the end of last
year
where to kind of relate to this too big
to fail question particularly with
respect to derivatives which had been
my expertise
particularly when i was back on wall
street
to ensure that banks that have too much
of a concentration of too many
derivatives on their books in other
words they're most likely
to be at the helm of
steering us into the next financial
crisis
would have to reduce their size reduce
their footprint by a certain amount so
that the very large banks that basically
were subsidized since the financial
crisis and control most of the
derivatives activity that happens
have to actually
reduce
their size
so it was a different way of getting at
that too big to fail size from the
standpoint of
actual legislation that was introduced
it was not passed
which is which is not surprising because
i think members on both sides of the
aisle tend to think that when banks say
we're okay now we've got this
that it's true
and um and and that's that's sort of the
situation which we find ourselves today
well folks on the hill tweets to you
please comment on the trump
administration trying to influence fed
policy how much influence does trump
have on the fed is that a good or bad
thing by the way monetary policy set by
the treasury department would be overtly
political
um
so it's it's it's interesting because
just going back to the
history of the creation of the fed
it was effectively created
as a marriage between politics and
finance i mean it really was
wall street working with the senate
finance committee to create an
institution that could help them in
times of trouble it wasn't like jekyll
island happened because jp morgan
decided to send a bunch of lieutenants
to his sort of club area to talk about
how to help farmers in iowa that just
wasn't why it happened
um so if you consider that was the the
initial sort of um mo of the fed and it
it has um you know issued yeah it's done
monetary policy and set rates for
different reasons to combat um inflation
or sort of price activities going
forward uh since then um that that's one
element if we look at what's happening
today there is still a relationship even
though it's was created as an
independent body
where it's its members our institutions
and it lives in washington
so it's it's very hard to really think
of it
as an independent body it wasn't created
independently
it's supposed to be independent but just
from the sheer pragmatics of it it isn't
really that said
i think when when president trump talked
about
that there shouldn't be rate hikes at
the end of last year what he was looking
at i think was less the economy and more
the markets as i was talking about
before he doesn't want the markets to go
down on his watch any more than
president obama wanted the markets to go
down on his watch it's just that he has
a much sort of more public way of of of
uh tweeting his opinion
then then happened under the obama
administration where rates didn't didn't
rise at all so what we have now is him
very publicly um having talked about
there shouldn't be any rate hikes and
then it turned out that that chairman
jerome powell and the flmc committee at
the fed decided not to raise rates for
the rest of this year so there is that
relationship is it because of trump
i don't know but i think what it's
because of is ultimately they're looking
at the same things which is they're
looking at data they're looking at the
markets and they're looking at not
on their watch having another financial
crisis so in that respect um they're
sort of allied as they were from the
beginning into right now uh when trump
said just recently that they should be
cutting rates right now and immediately
as did economic adviser larry kudlow and
then sort of a week later president
trump did
that's going further and sort of in the
same process saying look you did this
before you should do this again
and i think again even though the
economy is slowing it's not necessarily
because of the economy it's because of
the easier way to look at how money is
impacting
headline figures which is how it's
impacting the stock market which i think
they both look at
so nomi prince with your background and
your philosophy
what do you think when you see uh
president trump criticize
the fed chair
well
from the standpoint the fact that he put
the fed chair in his position
um it's just it's it's odd um but i mean
he's he's criticized other people that
he's um he's appointed um after he's
appointed them if they haven't done what
he's wanted them um to do but having
looked at um chairman powell's past
votes on on interest rates in general um
until he was in paris he basically voted
with the rest of the fomc committee he
voted
with janet yellen he was fairly
dovish and in fact
he only had a couple more rate hikes
under his time than janet yellen started
under under her time and and he would
have seen that
before criticizing
his actress his actual policy so i think
it's interesting just on a personal
level that you know you appoint someone
that you then criticize because they're
not doing what you want them to do and
and i think he wants them to do what he
wants them to do more quickly um as as
possibly with other entities in
washington but i also think that um
but but i also think it's just
an alignment that that he has looking at
markets that the fed has looking at
markets and ultimately um they're coming
out to the same conclusion which is that
there might possibly be a fed cut
in rates by the end of this year
and if it happens then chairman powell
will say it's because of data and
president trump will say it's because he
told them so it
the net result is going to be the same
harsh is in lexington mississippi and
you are on with author nomie prince
harsh
thank you for taking my call
my name is harsh doshi i'm a primary
care physician
who happened to come here in lexington
mississippi homes county
and my issues are very complicated i
came here to get my own green card which
took me almost three years to get a
green card because my son is a us-born
u.s citizen so what i have seen here
which i challenge anybody in the united
states of america to come and visit and
see the utter poverty and suffering of
the american people in the delta of
mississippi as a physician that's my
observation of 25 years a
b who is going to safeguard
the day-to-day american people who pick
up the garbage who work in the hospital
work as a janitor who take care of our
day-to-day life and if they become sick
there is no
way they can be cared upon a b if they
become sick and need disability it takes
months together
c
if something happens to these people
they barely get something where they
have to make a choice between paying for
the medicine or their own food
and d all these philanthropic people all
the government agencies they put money
why don't somebody come and visit here
i'm available to give them a tour i'm an
outsider looking at insider this is a
great country because of a scholastic
fairness i came to america because of
scholastic fairness if you lose the
scholastic fearless and give people the
understanding this is a free party no
it's not a free party i studied
outperformed and then i was given an
education in america harsh we're going
to leave it there i apologize
um harsh you know what you're talking
about is um
again something that that you know
unfortunately is is
not just the underbelly of of america
which which is great as a country um
on the whole but but it's also prevalent
throughout
throughout the country i remember when i
was writing um
jack my second book it was after um
katrina um the hurricane katrina had
happened and i spent time um in
louisiana and and in mississippi of
course that was after
a natural devastation but but it was um
apparent you know sort of
then that you know
having just living on the edge to begin
with and then obviously
compounding that with with a natural
disaster creates devastation that goes
past um any of the individuals involved
to their families to to people that work
with them to to companies that rely on
those people for their own benefit and
so forth that it's a knock-on effect and
i think what you're talking about um
from a health care primary health care
perspective that that you do
is is that as well it's that i think
people don't understand
that if we don't have a way
you know from an economic perspective
given that the mass amount of wealth
that we have as a country um to to
support the people that support um
not just themselves and their families
but but others
in need of of of medical care
than on multiple levels where we're
hurting ourselves if someone goes into a
hospital
and and they could be the richest person
in the world themselves they could have
access
to the best private health insurance
that there is out there
but if they are being cared for by
people who can't afford their own health
care
or have to choose between food and that
if there's a situation in their families
or for themselves
then that's a massive hole in our system
so i i believe that there is
primarily because in in many ways um we
do subsidize so many financial
activities um and speculative activities
in this country that we have the ability
to create a a way um to help through
an extended medicare for all program or
an extended disability program money
that's going into the system people have
already put in
um and and appropriate it in in a way
that actually looks
more at areas such as yours and
throughout the country
and from her book jacked nomi prinz
writes
let's make no mistake about this
insurance companies are middlemen their
sole job is to connect the dots that
stand between you and your medical
treatment more often than not it seems
like their job is actually to create red
tape between you and your wallet
why do we put up with them
right and that was written uh that book
came out in 2006 i think so so this was
before
um our conversations about
whether it is you know medicare for all
obamacare whatever you call it the
reality is insurance companies are
private brokers
um and their ceos get paid a lot of
money and their shareholders make a lot
of money in the process of of separating
people um from from their premiums
of raising premiums without a lot of a
limit or some states
with any limit really just what the
market can bear and ultimately what that
means is people don't get the health
care that they need in order to sustain
not just themselves but all of the
levels in the country of individuals who
rely on them
tavis eagle river alaska hi tavis
thanks so much for taking my call it's
been a fascinating listening to know me
and listening to the other callers
it's interesting when you look at the
history of economics you know i think a
lot of what nomi's touching on from the
free market standpoint a lot of this has
been
presented previously by ludwig von mises
hayak uh friedman people like murray
rothbard people like hans hermann hopa
talking about the effects of
fiat money on the economy
the effects of too much easy money in
the in the banking system if you look at
the financial crisis in 2008 i think it
i think it's probably a
pretty good case study when you have too
much fiat currency flying around
um i guess
and then i
just kind of
trying to figure out where nomi sits on
a lot of these issues it seems like some
aspect she's she's in favor of the free
market not in favor of too much fiat
currency but then she kind of has these
socialistic tendencies i guess my
question
one of my questions would be for nomi do
you think we should tend towards
a
commodity money and perhaps get back to
a gold standard
or do you think we should continue on
with this fiat
currency that we have and i'll just
leave a quote from keynes
and in the long run
we're all dead
so
i'll just leave it there tavis kind of
stole my thunder i was going to kind of
close with that i like that we were done
but uh i i didn't i didn't associate you
with frederick friedrich hayek
well um what's what's interesting and um
you know about about your your
statements i mean i
i think money is very complex and i
think markets are very complex and and
what we do with it um tends to you know
get labeled under under different sorts
of isms and political um sort of
fights
from the standpoint of the free market
um just just to really quickly on that i
don't think
we have free markets i think it's a kind
of theoretical construct by which and
the you know the sort of definition for
which would be full transparency and
full participation ability by all actors
in the market and and the minute and
this sort of relates to my theories
about about the fed or about fiat
currency or about subsidizing um the
main financial actors in in in that
environment you you by definition rig
the market i mean if you're subsidizing
one level of the market and that's the
market that has the most access and
volume um and influence and control over
the market we sort of get away from
free markets and in general just just
from a practicality standpoint by virtue
of how
our monetary system has been constructed
um that said um you know just just
because you mentioned in terms of my my
thoughts about how society um should
have
more of the economic benefits that that
that are produced by that society um to
sort of help it whether that's from a
health care standpoint or from security
standpoint police firemen education and
so forth i think that ultimately um
allows people to be responsive into that
economy be responsible to that economy
and that helps
from a foundation upward standpoint from
individual to local to small business
and so forth in a way that i think is
more secure for for everyone involved
in terms of
the gold standard because it is a
question that comes up
from a lot of people that have read my
books particularly the last
for it takes a pillage all the
president's bankers in collusion
one of the things that happened when
when the united states was taken off of
the gold standard in 1971 under the
nixon administration was that all of a
sudden
um
banks didn't have to kind of reserve to
gold the fed didn't have to reserve as
much to go there was no anchor um to to
to the financial system there was no
there's no currency anchor um to the
dollar and and by subsequent
just definition to other um currencies
outside the dollar that were pegged to
the dollar and so all of a sudden you
had the ability to create more money
because there was nothing
anchoring that money and that was a
situation that was pushed primarily
by the banks
and it was pushed primarily by the banks
because they they knew that um they knew
that it was much easier um to create
money if you didn't have to also connect
it to to some hard asset or some sort of
other standard on the outside of that
creation you could you could just do
more it was it was a way actually of of
deregulating
the monetary system i don't think just
just from the sheer standpoint of
pragmatism
to throw out in ism at you that we're
going back to a gold standard in fact
um ben bernanke and i i have a lot of um
some of the things that he said
specifically to congress in in collusion
um about the gold standards he went
actually on a defense on a sort of
defensive movement against the gold
standard being brought back when no one
was even asking him that question when
the financial crisis was at its height
two banks and two congress which is
interesting because it was basically
saying like look we need to create money
right now so this is really just not the
time to be talking
about pegging it that said
there are central banks who do
stockpile more gold and do think not
that we're going to go back to a gold
standard but that it could potentially
be part of
a sort of more global currency or
benchmark that will include pieces of a
gold standard which would at least also
give some sort of a peg
to simply being able to create dollars
or to create money just
at will
lawrence tweets in can you explain where
the fed gets its initial funding for its
balance sheets does congress appropriate
it
um that's interesting congress
appropriates things like
it's um
how it pays its people and sort of um
it's it's space and and sort of more
alert of logistic types of things in
terms of its actual money it's it's it's
created like
um a corporation and it gives shares out
like a corporation so that the members
um or the big banks um are like
shareholders in in this corporation and
based on that and based on the reserves
that they put um onto the balance sheet
of the federal reserve is sort of how
the fed ultimately um gets the money to
be able to to utilize that said it's
also an electronic process now so it
used to be
that there was reserves or there was
gold put against federal reserve notes
which was that basically the fed would
use those as collateral and then issue
fed notes on the back of that now it can
be created electronically and so there's
um actually through 1941 there were
reports that came out from the fed that
talked about how the member banks
actually how many shares they owned and
how much those shares are worth and how
much they were putting in for them um
those reports haven't been available for
you know since world war ii um but for
the most part it's the larger banks who
have more of uh the percentage of of the
fed and and sort of also
put in more of the reserves to the
federal reserve to be able to operate
robert temecula california please go
ahead you're on book tv with author
nomie prince well hi thank you very much
i'm blind so hopefully your book will
have an audio
um subscription to it but anyway my i
want to be on the devil's advocate side
here and the way i look at california
conversely and arguably they say it has
the sixth largest economy in the world
and at silicon valley six largest yet we
have the highest rate
of welfare
and poverty than any other state even
the southern states we have such
and they say silicon valley takes away
its money and takes it out of country
and they won't even invest it in our
banks and that really worries me and i
wonder is you i i think you're more
liberal i would say
i have no problem with that as long as
the money gets distributed right but it
just seems that silicon valley
and the way they run
out of our country with the money i mean
how do you
you seem
to argue
the point against wall street but you
don't say anything about silicon valley
so
what would you do about that all right
robert thank you very much first of all
the audio have you recorded audio
versions yeah in fact robert there is
there are audio versions to
to all of my books or at least the last
three books that i know of
and in fact the one for uh collusion um
which is the one that the most recent
book um i i think is is phenomenal um
did you do the audio yourself i didn't
but um i know that that um it was done
and because there's a lot of names in in
in collusion a lot of you know chinese
names japanese names sort of
non-american form and um and and that
the woman who actually does the audio
spent a lot of time
on the language on making sure things
were accurate as well as making it of
what could be considered dry
you know the story of central banks in
the last 10 years a very entertaining
topic i i think she did a good job on
that so hopefully you'll be able to
listen to those um you know from the
standpoint of silicon valley it's
interesting because um
you want to talk about the wall street
banks or the major banks and the
influences they've had it's it's been
over a long period of our history and
our evolution as a country the evolution
of our political system um you know our
sort of dominance as a superpower as the
major reserve currency and so many other
things that have happened
whereas a lot of the tech companies are
very
new to that aspect although that said
i think last year they overtook wall
street in terms of lobbying money and in
terms of what they were pouring in to
get um you know what they wanted from a
legislative or policy perspective um for
for for their companies as they grow and
certainly many of them don't pay any
taxes and um
president trump talked about getting
taxes back on shore president obama
talked about getting taxes back on shore
president bush talked about getting
those taxes back on shore before google
was google and you know facebook was
facebook um and so this has been a
problem in general on particularly in
technology where a lot of the work is is
is kind of done in
in more of the ether you're not
necessarily building the bridge in front
of where the ambridge is about to be
built and bringing all the sort of
construction aspects to it and physical
people and everything else you can
actually do these um
these jobs in in multiple different
places and it's easy to create uh
different kinds of uh you know sort of
hubs in different countries and and not
pay taxes um and i i do think that's a
problem i i i think if an individual um
is is basically paying um and and this
is data actually from um from from our
last um
census but basically if you look at the
number of individuals in the country
what we're paying um in in terms of
multiple taxes so a combination of
income taxes um social security taxes
employment taxes and so forth into the
country what corporations pay
as a percentage of revenue the actual
money that goes to the treasury
department
and then ultimately gets appropriated
through the budget process in in
washington is only um you pick a year
but in the last 10 years somewhere
between 7 to 11 percent of all of the
money that comes into washington so on
that basis individuals are paying
a lot more and small business owners a
lot more than the larger corporations
are paying which is which is a very
small proportion so
i i believe that's wrong you know i i
think companies um that have the benefit
of um you know so the american
population as workers the american
consumers consumers and even the global
environment to pick both
should be paying more taxes to the
country um in which they're actually
domiciled not the country um you know
which they on paper um exist in
nomie prince a lot of email tweets and
facebook comments along this line
as a retiree with investments how can i
best protect myself
that's from george again several uh
several
comments like that
and then a follow-up from and that's
george in maryland this is george in
florida
what do you do with your money
okay
um those are those are great questions
on the retiree side um
or even if you're sort of younger but
looking at the fact that you want to
live
as long as
um into your retirement and as long as
possible we'll need to to finance that
um i i think there's a couple of things
one is the the the older you get
the more secure what you have should be
um so so i think um and it's hard now
because rates are so low right so if you
have retirement money in a savings
account with say jpmorgan chase um
you're now getting like a quarter of a
percent interest on that whereas you
know for example if you if you put that
retirement money that's the savings part
into something like you know an american
express bank online or an aspiration uh
com bank online then that money is
getting over 2.12.2
interest so right there on on a secure
basis you know just on money that you
want to not do anything with or or just
keep and i do that she asked me what i
do with my money i don't have savings
accounts in any of the large
banks in this country because they just
don't they just don't pay enough
relative to other places i could put
that savings um and so that's one
example of what i would recommend for
secure money for retiree as well as um
what i do
in terms of 401k plans or or pension
plans coming in
there's a couple of things one is i
think you should always be aware of what
you have and how it's changing on a
regular basis and a lot of people just
kind of look at their statements when
something
bad happens or when something good
happens but you're not monitoring them
as they're changing and i think what you
might see if you monitor them as you
change
and ask these questions is that
sometimes your money is managed by
companies that
make money off of effectively trading
your money
and and your 401k plan or your pension
plan has to basically pay for the charge
of executing each transaction that they
execute against your account and it
might not be you individually might be
like where your where your account lives
it could be yours individually so it's
important to have control of your 401k
um and if you are having an outside
manager have it be someone who who is a
fiduciary someone who's responsible to
to your money and not necessarily um to
a major company they might be working
for um or a bank that might also have a
an asset management element that your
401k is housed with and so therefore it
kind of trades with what the bank wants
it to trade even though it's not
supposed to but that's just kind of what
happens um and and it's more um it loses
less um in that process um and and i
think those are two things i do i mean i
i look at my money kind of religiously
in that respect because one thing i'll
tell you is that you make a lot more
money on wall street than you make as a
journalist that's just a thing out there
if anyone thinks there's there's there's
a major difference you're right but what
that means is it's very important for me
to preserve what i have um and and i do
that by being very careful about not
giving it away
first off and money that i know i want
to keep with me have it get rated as
high as it can in terms of interest and
then make sure i'm not paying fees and
all sorts of extra things along the way
because those little adjustments um or
or even looking at your credit cards and
not paying any higher rates and getting
them down to a zero or getting them down
to nothing or transferring balances
those actually make you money especially
when you compound that um when you look
at how your money grows over time to and
through your retirement
getting rid of your costs um is is huge
from nomie prin's book jacked she writes
banks spend hours
determining how to use your relationship
with them to suck money from you
take fees there's no reason banks have
to charge people to access their own
money and yet what happens if you can't
maintain a minimum balance you pay a fee
don't do direct deposit because you need
the cash from your paycheck immediately
pay a fee next call david hot springs
village arkansas hi david
how do i
i'm interested in
the history of
goldman sachs and therefore i read
william goldman's book
and i'm wondering if you read it the
thing that struck me about it was
uh gus levy your legendary principal
partner there
was able to get on the board of
at least a dozen of the fortune 500
maybe even the fortune 100 companies and
then come back and trade on the
information he'd get he'd be getting at
these board meetings and i just wonder
if you had read that book and what you
think of that and my other question is
very simple do you think thomas picketty
has nailed it
thank you
thank you sir um excellent questions i i
actually i think i reviewed that book
for the daily beast back when it came
out um so so yes i did um it's it's it's
a very well researched it's it's it's a
big book i think his last name is not
it's um william
uh anyway we'll get our producer we'll
get it um
sorry about that um however um yes one
of the things that happened throughout
sort of even the initial history of
goldman sachs and i i talk about this in
all the president's bankers because it's
kind of a fascinating set of
relationships and in particular um was
even before for that
sydney weinberg um who was around the
time of of the crash in 1929 he was
running goldman sachs as it was
participating um in a lot of what were
called trusts back then now they're
called cdos and close and other things
but basically uh you know
conglomerations of of uh of stocks and
other securities that might not be doing
that well or might have to have stories
be told about them in order to get
people to buy them but we're put into
these trusts which ultimately lost all
of their value when when the market
crashed in 1929 and the way sydney
weinberg who was running goldman at the
time thought he could get through this
was to become friends with a uh well the
governor of new york
a man named franklin delano roosevelt
who ultimately became the president of
the country
why did president roosevelt become
president roosevelt well one of the
things that he had was sydney weinberg
and a bunch of people in the business
community that weinberg aggregated um
contribute to his campaign so even
though he's considered a traitor to his
class the reality is just if you follow
the money back to his initial um
campaign and his initial coming into
office um is that sydney weinberg and
actually another fellow named joe
kennedy who was kennedy's um father jeff
kay's father um we're helping him to
create money weinberg in new york
kennedy in in california and as a result
fdr appointed a new council called the
business council um at the time on which
he put the head um sydney weinberg so
city weinberg has a redeemed goldman and
redeemed
wall street in the eyes of of fdr in the
country in a way
by
getting his friends
to that he invested with and that
invested with him
to basically support the incoming
president and he saw the writing on the
tea leaves that kind of thing has
continued um throughout throughout uh
you know time since there's a tremendous
number of what what are called
interlocking board memberships um
between institutions um and also a a
vast percentage of people in congress
own stocks
in companies that
doesn't take a rocket scientist to
figure out how they're related to policy
that those very congress people might be
promoting
so that that that still happens
phil portland oregon please go ahead
with your question or comment for know
me prince
well thank you fans for taking the call
and yeah where to begin after all you
said
um i'll put it up as a the political
football question of 2020
can a president get the 10 percent
to pay a fair share tax to restrict
america's infrastructure
i mean the mercers the purdue's the
waltons the coax they all laugh in
america's face and americans like you
and me
and try to keep as much money as they
can and not pay anything
can a president elected
get 10 percent from the wealthy without
creating a civil war between the house
and have nets that's phil in portland
oregon so that that's an interesting
question because um you know under this
administration we've kind of gone the
opposite way um
in terms of taxes um there's no
particular reason the math would work
better on on on that kind of a tax
that's that's a proportion it's more of
a proportion tax um throughout the
entire country so that so that the
wealthier pay up to a certain amount um
a a higher percentage into the tax
system and beyond that
a different percentage perhaps but that
is a way to bring in money into the the
treasury department which ultimately is
where the money is taken
into the budget process and and
ultimately that money can get
appropriated into things like
infrastructure
we we have a tremendous infrastructure
deficit in this country um
everyone who was nominated everyone was
in in the process trying to get elected
uh last election including president
trump talked about paying money into
infrastructure um it's it's it's a
problem that we have uh you know bridges
that are falling apart and ports that
are that are old and and railways that
are slow and you know hospitals that are
in need of better equipment or roads to
get to them or whatever it might be that
that again that's a significant pan
economic problem for the country and and
retrieving uh money from companies or or
the wealthy that use more of those
benefits because they they ultimately
depending on what they're running could
be utilizing more of the infrastructure
that they need would actually benefit
them as well back when president
eisenhower was was president um
republican president had a lot of
bankers and company men and stuff around
him who propped him into that position
after having been a general during world
war ii um he came up with a plan to
build our nation's highways he came up
with that plan and he raised taxes and
he built the highways and he presided
over a number of economic booms not just
for the people at the top of the country
getting back to the other caller who's
talking about piketty who talks about
inequality being a problem but but
throughout the rest of the country and
an anecdote that i found going through
a lot of the files i spent time
a lot of time in kansas actually looking
at president eisenhower's um notes and
all the um documents from that period in
history um is that there was a a person
who was a banker at the morgan bank at
the time some of the most powerful banks
still and then at the time who said to
president eisenhower in a letter he said
look if you
create a tax system
whereby
those of us who have those are the p and
he was rich so the people that have less
money
actually can keep more of their money
and the people who have more money have
to pay a little bit more of their money
into the system ultimately you have a
stronger economy he was a millionaire he
was working one of the major banks in
the country and this was in a letter
that he wrote to eisenhower where he
advocated
this kind of a more proportional tax
system because he believed that the more
money was actually in more people's
pockets throughout the country the
better ultimately the entire economy
would be it would lift those people and
it would lift all of the business owners
and wealthy people at the top of that
and that was one of the things inside
the philosophy for
for the highway programs it wasn't the
only thing but but eisenhower did did
listen um to people a lot he
communicated um he a lot um through
letters and and he he took people's
opinions um very seriously and and so
this was something that worked to the
benefit of the country
and was something that was postulated by
its wealthiest members
this is from the preface of all the
president's bankers you talk about your
research
all of the national archives and records
administration libraries for fdr through
carter have exceedingly accessible and
well-organized information with
consistent classifications they were a
pleasure to peruse and i lost myself for
days in all of them
after reagan took office records became
less available at the clinton library in
little rock i learned that some records
may never be uncovered without the
benefit of a freedom of information act
request not merely for national security
reasons but because the commitment to
organize such a vast amount of material
is not what it was before the 1980s
as such the bulk of information that
might be revealed by the four-year
request that i filed at the reagan
george h w bush and clinton libraries is
not available yet
so it's interesting because since that
time
um i actually
did i i did
file foia requests with the clinton
library
and with the
george w bush library
senior
and i wound up ultimately getting some
of those requests back to me
from the clinton library
um and it's interesting it took a number
of years um and and they they did
respond to some of them they didn't
respond to others what i what i had
studied or tried to get at um at the
clinton library was what happened into
the repeal of the glass-steagall act in
1999 because there was an awful lot of
activity um that was that was going on
back and forth between in particular um
the the city bank
had sandy weil and the the clinton
administration and congress and so forth
so what i was trying to do because it
was happening during the time of
clinton's administration
is try to get as much of that as i could
and what i found because the
classification systems in general and in
the presidential libraries became
more difficult
to access and and the funding to them
became less so the librarians had more
difficulty access them and some of it
was classified a lot of it was
classified it it was difficult but
ultimately they got me some material
after the book came out
and i used some of it in in the in the
paperback version um and then some of it
is actually still uh still is coming in
but but not all of it is exactly what i
asked
so so i have to admit that even though i
i did get some material back from
clinton's library i haven't gotten it
back yet from from the bush one and even
from the clinton library um it's become
difficult and my guess is going forward
in time
and i think i talked about this in the
very end of the president's bankers when
you get to the obama administration or
you get to the trump administration or
whoever we have going forward it becomes
harder and harder to really get access
to that information
because now it's electronic there's all
sorts of national security labels put on
all sorts of redactions um and every
piece of every email has to go through
analysis as to whether it's a security
risk to even get um
basically the the access uh that the
foia would would uh would require from
it so it's it's it's difficult times
have changed no me prince i know this
isn't your area of writing but did
george washington have a relationship
with bankers
um that is an interesting question um i
i don't know if he did i know john adams
um did have a relationship with bankers
um and that and that the adams family in
general um in terms of financing their
their own sort of um rising as well as
what he thought of banking thomas
jefferson as well i am not entirely sure
about george washington um himself so
someone had to finance you know some of
those wars and and in a lot of cases um
even even the initial war that created
our country um you you had to have
financing to do that and and oftentimes
it was financiers who were involved with
the army and with
ultimately the government who helped to
provide some of that and during world
war ii were banks important to fdr
banks were very important in world war
ii um if we even look at sort of the
memories of that and in terms of um war
bonds that were issued through the banks
to individuals there were situations i
mean
i looked up documents where you could
see um you know ads being put out by um
by say chase to the population in new
york city to say like you know open up
an account get a war bond certificate it
was all sorts of deals um that were
being sort of run by by banks as well as
them providing some of their own um
money into the war effort um as well as
directing some of that war effort and
and different banks provided different
funds to different elements of the war
and also the countries outside to our
allies you know whether it was like
going to the uk um going to germany as
well on the other side so definitely
they had a role um in in the financing
and the raising of finances for that
warren during that period in history
where i talk about world war ii um
there's a lot of um
there's a lot of communication going
back and forth between sort of the
people that were running um these
institutions like tom lamont who was
running the morgan bank at the time
and the president's um sort of staff as
well as fdr
um before we leave collusion
what's the role of the imf and the world
bank in the world
money
situation yeah so talking about coming
out of world war ii
the idea was and a meeting was held in
1944 in bretton woods new hampshire
where um sort of leaders
of the winners of the international sort
of community came together to talk about
how to fund ultimately the reparations
um that needed to be done in the wake of
war um so so so the argument for the imf
the international monetary fund and the
world bank um came out of two things one
to have some sort of a currency element
that could work throughout the world so
that we could basically look at
financing what were at the time
a lot of devastations and money required
for those devastations around the world
because of world war ii um for the war
and then by extension um other countries
who had suffered because of the economic
um downturns that that were caused by
the war um that needed funding to to be
developed now that's changed over the
years since um to having you know
funding that's based on development you
know developing countries um and and
helping with anything down to you know
building a waterway from a village to
sort of a major river to more complex
and larger funded programs and these and
these um and these monetary system
components are also run by different
individuals from different parts of the
world so the idea is that they're an
international sort of base of
development related money um the world
bank was actually run the second
president of the world vancouver was run
by a man named john mccloy who became
the chairman of chase after he became
the head of the second head of the world
bank
and that relationship again had
something to do with chase or or banks
would go out to the public and they
would try to raise money that would then
go back to the world bank that the world
bank could then use for projects
that they deemed
appropriate or necessary and then the
world bank would find the task teams and
sort of work on distributing that money
out to those particular projects
one final character before we run out of
time that you spend a lot of time with
david rockefeller
so david rockefeller's is very
interesting because he was at the crux
of a major shift that happened um
throughout the relationship between
banking and
washington between wall street and the
presidency and and that was that he came
from a time where there was a depression
and and where his family or the
rockefellers actually owned a
significant portion or the rockefeller
aldrich is which was going back to
nelson aldrich and his son winthrop he
married into the rockefeller family so
abby rockefeller and winthrop aldridge
had children etc they became
david rockefeller nelson rockefeller and
other rockefellers so so that the family
itself was fascinating i'm summarizing
but it goes through multiple decades of
this family being involved in elements
of wall street elements of global policy
of nelson rockefeller became the vice
president while david rockefeller was
running chase
which at the time was a major bank of it
still is it's jpmorgan chase is the
largest bank in the united states it was
a major power player
at chase but david rockefeller during
his time as he was rising to become the
chairman of chase um was also working
more and more outwardly with other sort
of foreign policy initiatives like
working more closely with the middle
east and finding ways for
middle east money or petro dollars money
that was made out of oil to be used as
currency as collateral for loans that
that chase could make to latin america
or to other developing countries and
make money off of that so rather than be
fully aligned as they had been
historically to the united states
government for money and therefore very
symbiotic relationship and influence
chain they now through him have this
ability to access money that was coming
in from an external place and
lend it to another external place and in
that way to take themselves into
a position where they could more control
what the government was doing as opposed
to have to be a team player
because they had now this extra pot of
money coming from somewhere else he was
also very much an advocate of going off
of the gold standard and everything else
through that whole 1970s period to allow
banks to have
larger access to pools of capital and
just a larger um general footprint so
he's interesting for for for a lot of
reasons i mean yeah his he goes back to
having you know balls with the kennedys
in london i mean lots of things are
interesting in his life as well john
mccloy who i mentioned had worked with
doc david rockefeller
throughout his earlier
career and had grown through that
relationship ultimately to become a very
you know become the head of the world
bank and become the head of chase so a
lot of individuals that move between
politics and global monetary systems and
banks and society sort of all tied in
somehow to david rockefeller and she
tells that story in her book all the
president's bankers in case you're
interested nomi prinz in our last minute
let's bring all these pieces together
for the past two hours
what in your view is a solution to this
hundred plus years of banking
regulation law
and the government well it's a couple
pieces one is i think that you know we
we do have to reinstate a glass-steagall
because we do have to separate not just
our banking system but globally banking
systems because we you know thanks copy
banks um
from the money that's put in through
people's deposits um and through their
loans and through the credit that they
require for themselves or their small
businesses or or what have you from the
more speculative activities that that
banks do because without doing that um
and it's important to to to
make that split
we will have a situation where the
federal reserve and other central banks
will be have no choice in their minds
and in their policies but to continue to
subsidize the very risk and the very
bets that these institutions place upon
society while they're saying
everything's okay they always will say
everything's okay particularly if
they're not the ones holding the bag at
the other side and there's some other
resource or pool whether it's in the
government or whether it's at the fed
that can help them in that time of
trouble so i think that's that's one
major thing that needs to be done and
from that
everything relates author and journalist
nomie prinz has been our guest on
in-depth thank you thank you so much
thank you for all the years
and if you missed any of today's program
we're going to re-air it right now
now